A BACKHANDER, SLICK PASS
COLUMBUS.
FORCED A TURN OVER.
HE SHOOTS AND ob: FIRST ONE SIN
>> NOVEMBER 2018.
ITLIST OF TO
HOLD, MALKIN ALL THE  IN THE GL
HELLEBUYCK BOTH OF THESE FIRE.
THEY'RE AT BOTH
ENDS!
TRISTAN JARRY WITH ONE
>> Steve: THE PENALTY, LATE
STAGE OF OFF THE ATTACK
HERE.
THAT WAS CROSBY, A HIHIAT NEXT
WHEELER, 2017 AND
TOO MANY CHANCES FOR A SNIPER G
TO BACK BUCAN'T GET IT IT OFF F
SECOND TIME.
SCORE, KAPANEN IN FRONT!
PENS T THERE.
THERE IS NO KICKING MOTION.
THAT ONE GAME, TURN OVER CARTER
TO
CARTER WHO ANTICIPATES, KNOWS
HELLEBUYCK HAS TO SCRAMBLE GRIN
HITTING.
YOU GOT MALKIN, LETANG,
EVERYBYBGLASS.
MORRISSEY CLOSING IN. N
JARRY GETS ACROSS.
>> Bob: CUTS IN
OVER TIME.
JOSH MORRISSEY, OVER FOR
WINNIPEG.
BLOCK IT WITH
THAT'S ONE WHERE UNTIL THE GOAL
BE TANG SCORES.
PENGUINS WIN.
HE DOWNTHE FIVE HOLE
AND